the recent college admissions scandal
revealed just how far some will go to
get into a top school even crossing the
line into criminality but for students
like Kevin Victoria the son of Colombian
immigrants starting starting at Stanford
this week might have been more than he
dared to dream if not for a unique
mentorship program that's been lighting
away look at you you look so happy oh
yeah when it comes to blessings
Kevin Victoria counts everyone oh look
at that yeah his family friends and a
future
he can't stop smiling about thanks in
part to a special nonprofit called
Latino you college access also known as
Luca if you could put a price tag on
what this program is done for you what
would it be priceless
they helped me so much I keep thinking
of ways to kind of be able to show my
gratitude and how like happy I am and
how like they've made me get to this
point I'm so proud Shirley Acevedo is
the founder of the program which
partners with local high schools that
have 50% or more Hispanic students
mostly low income the first thing that
we do with our Latino youth scholars is
we match them with trained volunteer
college coaches the coaches assist
students with everything from building a
college list to writing their college
essays to identifying scholarships for
which to apply which is exactly the kind
of help Kevin needed when applying to
schools without it his admission to
Stanford might not have been possible so
anybody who out there who says you know
I did this all by was so you're like
nobody does that all by themselves and
unfortunately some people don't have
that luxury I acknowledge the fact that
I'm at a disadvantage compared to other
people that have gotten into the
Stanford and I needed a little bit more
help not because I wasn't qualified to
go to the school not because I wasn't a
competitive applicant but just because
of the fact that I didn't know how to
navigate the process you needed that
exposure exactly Kevin is
is really an unusual kid he is smart and
energetic and competent and a great
sense of self that just just won't quit
husband-and-wife coaches amy and scott
silverstein help make stanford a reality
for kevin by assisting with the
application process
the first thing we attack is the the
common app essay because everything
about who he is and and what he's
dreaming of and what he's thinking about
is all wrapped up in that issue so it's
a great place to start I was conceived
on a drunken summer evening in his essay
Kevin tells his story which began in
Columbia where he was born as the result
of an affair and brought to this country
when he was just 2 years old
what has your family sacrificed to get
you here they left their family behind
they went into a place that the language
is unfamiliar to them and that's
ultimately the biggest sacrifice that
you can kind of do for your children
being able to sacrifice everything that
you know and everything that you're used
to to give them a better opportunity and
to maybe give them just a little bit of
a leg up for that reason he tried his
best in school and aimed for a brighter
future but to him that meant a state
school in New York I just never imagined
myself applying to any schools above
that cuz I didn't I thought it was too
out of reach yeah way reach way reach on
both what both financially and
academically ya know the major thing was
financially these children with the same
level of potential and academic ability
are not aware of what options exist for
them they're afraid to aim high because
they think that these institutions are
not meant for them Kevin worked with the
Silverstein's at least once a week for 4
to 5 hours at a time that effort paid
off what colleges were you accepted to I
was accepted to Stanford University Yale
University and Harvard University and
those are the only three colleges you
apply to yep are you kidding me no CUNY
no Buffalo State nope go big or go home
yeah
kevin is at Stanford this fall on a full
financial rod so why did you choose
Stanford there was just this feeling
that I got while I was at Stanford that
kind of made me feel like that was the
path that I'm supposed to go on like
your garden and now you have a bounty
the impact of this work is
transformational transformational not
only for the students that we serve but
for their parents who have put all of
their hopes and dreams in the potential
of their child being the first in their
family to go to college it's
transforming an entire life for
generations to come and let's face it
people with money can access a variety
of resources that's for the kids and
this is only providing that for free to
kids who can't afford and then affecting
the rest of the generations to come
great story Michele